ted m says what do you think about the
quiet quitting trend ted i think there's
a much bigger trend that nobody's paying
attention to which is the never applying
in the first place trend if you talk to
the average 16 to 22 year old they are
uncomfortably aware that making fifty
thousand dollars a year seventy thousand
dollars a year selling stuff on facebook
marketplace or ebay making google
adwords doing small brand deals on tick
tock companies are gonna have a tough
time getting people in for under 100k
when there's so many goddamn options for
these kids to make money on the internet
these kids are not growing up with the
world we grew up with we [ __ ] on gen z
for being entitled and lazy and what
they're being is thoughtfully
understanding of their options that's
interesting so i believe you have to
provide extra value i'm sitting in a
room with andrew who's filming me he's
investing in me and the opportunity it's
not just a job he's making a bet too he
saw what happened to the people before
him it gives him confidence that it's a
bet worth taking we as companies are
going to have to come up with concepts
that enable these youngsters to make a
bet worth taking because the alternative
is more interesting